helium is not a renewable resource at
least not only human time scale it's not
a fossil fuel but it is made very slowly
by radioactive decay deep down on the
ground so in terms of managing it we
should be treating it like a fossil fuel
once it's pulled up from the ground used
and dispersed into the atmosphere it is
ludicrously expensive to recover and
over time
that dispersed helium is light enough
and unreactive enough that eventually
very very slowly it escapes off into
space which is a problem because helium
is enormous ly useful we used in all
sorts of science and medicine to keep
the magnets in MRI machines cool in
manufacturing processes and yes to
inflate blimps and party balloons and
over the last decade or so there have
been a lot of breathless news articles
proclaiming that the world is running
out of helium a lot of the world's
helium comes from under the Great Plains
of the USA and here in Amarillo Texas
the US government has the National
helium reserve at least they do for now
we're standing on top of the Bush dome
the reservoir that actually access the
storage reservoir which is approximately
3,500 feet underground as a sponge
absorbs water and and holds that water
in the sponge
similarly the small pores in the rock
are spaces where the helium can reside
it's solid rock to the eye but it is
porous and allows the gas to be stored
very efficiently underground this
reservoir was a natural gas reservoir it
was depleted then recharged in the 60s
with 32 billion cubic feet of helium
into the ground so it's it's actually
helium that we've injected previously
that we're extracting now the whole
program was to conserve the helium for
about a hundred years of the consumption
rate then of course helium has become
such a popular element and has so many
uses that now that rate has quite a bit
more than originally estimated that
helium has been withdrawn over struck
cently fifteen years and we are now
reaching the end of our program as the
the field is declining in pressure
helium is notoriously known for being
able to escape through any small opening
it's used as a leak detection substance
you can detect helium very easily and if
it's able to get out you have
hole somewhere in that device or product
by putting it back in the ground it's
not leaking out of a stainless steel
container or a big truck it's easily
monitored and controlled the plant here
is in its annual week of maintenance
right now which is one of the reasons
I'm allowed to get quite this close
there are still parts I'm not allowed to
show you though the equipment behind me
is actually an enrichment unit all that
gas that was stored in the ground has
mixed and blended with natural gas from
the field and it's no longer in an
enriched State so by bringing it through
the equipment we actually take that gas
back up to approximately 80% purity of
helium about 20 percent impurity of
nitrogen that's actually what we produce
and send up our 425 mile pipeline to
then private helium plants that then
take it to a hundred percent there are
places in the world that are running out
of helium that's correct but there's
still approximately eighty to a hundred
years worth of known helium reserves in
the United States in Wyoming so to say
that we're running out of helium is
actually a little bit incorrect there's
still a lot of helium available and new
helium sources being found with the
recent increases in the helium price
that's actually stimulated industry to
go look for more helium resources and
they have found more so we expect that
in the next few years more of this
helium will be brought to market and
this this shortage will be alleviated at
least for a short period of time running
out of something on our current
planetary scale doesn't mean they're
suddenly won't be any at all it just
means that the price of what's left will
rise higher and higher and higher until
the lower supply meets lower demand
which might make some more difficult to
reach reservoirs of helium under the
ground worth exploring that's capitalism
because of all that uncertainty the
price of helium has been fluctuating a
lot over the last few years and
researchers are often having trouble
finding enough money to keep their
experiments going and yes it's why
filling party balloons is getting really
expensive we are now in the final two
years of our program and facing the last
part of our privatization effort by the
year 2021 we will be stepping out of the
helium activity and transferring it to
private entities surprisingly enough the
question comes up
out whether or not we should be using
party balloons I happen to be a real fan
of party balloons so for my preference
you know I still I'm glad that we have
party balloons with the price of helium
where it is there's so much conservation
going on now that the party balloons are
actually a very small part of the market
we've seen now in recent years with the
newer helium sources coming online and
this great effort towards helium
conservation that that's really had an
impact in making more helium available
for everyone so I think the party
balloons kind of got a bad rap I did
think about ending this video by
delivering my conclusion in a silly
voice by breathing from a helium balloon
but honestly we do need to conserve
helium and I figured that would set a
bad example so this it's just regular
air I'm glad that flew away that would
look terrible if it hadn't worked